welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is eboo Patel the founder and president
of interfaith youth core he is at Yale
to give the coca-cola world fund lecture
at the McMillan center named by US News
and World Report as one of America's
best leaders of 2009 mr. Patel is the
author of the book sacred ground
pluralism prejudiced and the promise of
America and his 2007 autobiography acts
of faith the story of an American Muslim
the struggle for the soul of a
generation he is also a member of
President Obama's Advisory Council of
the White House Office of faith-based
and neighborhood partnerships today we
talk with mr. Patel about his new book
sacred ground welcome great to be with
you Marilyn thank you let's begin with
the organization you found it interfaith
youth core tell us about it and why you
felt it was important to found it sure
so the idea for interfaith youth core
hit me probably 15 years ago I was a
college student in the early to
mid-1990s at a time when the
multicultural movement was at an
inflection point and service-learning
was a big deal in college campuses also
and there were a lot of projects and
organizations that were bringing people
of different racial and ethnic
backgrounds together to do service Teach
for America city year and it kind of
occurred to me as I was deepening into
my own Muslim identity at the time and
as I was studying other religions and
their calls to serve others why why not
bring Hindus and humanists Muslims and
Buddhists Jews and Catholics together to
do service all of our religions call us
to serve others service is a great way
of bringing people from different
backgrounds together in a common project
so that was the against the original
animating idea of interfaith youth core
and it's it's grown into a really
ambitious organization and movement and
the kind of generational goal of
interfaith
Youth Court is to help make social to
help make interfaith cooperation a
social norm and the way that human
rights or that volunteerism or that
civil rights are social norms and we
believe that college campuses are kind
of many civil societies that can model
interfaith cooperation for the rest of
the country and that college students
can be inspired and trained and
mobilized to be interfaith leaders so
that's what we do at interfaith youth
core we partner with college campuses to
help them model interfaith cooperation
and we run interfaith leadership
Institute's for college students to
become interfaith leaders okay and then
do you track that the pattern out when
they go graduate and go out into the
world I mean do they continue that kind
of work that's a great question so that
is a part of you know to use kind of a
nerdy term that's kind of a that's part
of our theory of change this notion that
college students if they if they begin
to view themselves as interfaith leaders
during a formative stage in their lives
and their 18 19 20 years old and if they
have a chance to apply the knowledge
base and skill set of interfaith
leadership on their campuses by running
something we call a better together
campaign that that's their first steps
towards leading a life of interfaith
leadership and we have a really robust
alumni program at interfaith youth core
that helps college students do
everything from go on to divinity school
to study world religions and interfaith
leadership or to go on to be doctors
lawyers hedge fund managers washington
DC types who will take the perspective
of interfaith leadership into whatever
vocation or a career path they choose
and for us our definition of interfaith
leadership is pretty straightforward and
concrete it's an interfaith leader is
somebody with the knowledge based on
skill set to build understanding and
cooperation amongst people and groups
who orient around religion differently
and you can do that if you're a doctor
in a hospital you can do that if you're
a lawyer and a law firm you could
certainly do that if you're a pastor or
a rabbi or an imam you could do that if
you're in the business world and we
think that that's going to be one of the
key kind of frameworks and skill sets of
the 21st century in this highly
religiously diverse world in which too
often faith is a barrier of division we
need a critical mass
of people who are inspired and trained
and skilled to help faith become a
bridge of cooperation and can you give
me some examples of specifically how the
bridges are built and how people go
about working together that's a great
question thank you for that so this goes
back to kind of the the original
animating idea behind interfaith youth
core which is that service is something
that all of our faith traditions and
secular traditions call us to do and
service is a great common table for
people to gather around so what we what
we train students to do in our
interfaith leadership Institute's is run
interfaith service and dialogue projects
and I'll give you a great example from
my alma mater the University of Illinois
so the better together group and that's
what these groups tend to be called at
campuses across the country the better
together or interfaith an action group
at the University of Illinois would have
kind of monthly interfaith dialogue
meetings of their group and then every
year they would run something called the
interfaith an action day and for several
years it was modest in size like a
hundred to 150 students and a handful of
campus administrators which show up and
you know kind of was getting a start
like a lot of student groups do and then
a couple years ago there was that
terrible earthquake in Haiti in the
leadership of that better together group
at University of Illinois decided that
that they wanted to do something really
big and significant to help folks who
were suffering from that earthquake and
so they organized this huge interfaith
service campaign and project in the
university of illinois campus and
community that brought over 5,000 people
from different religious and secular
communities together to package over a
million meals for people who suffered
from the earthquake in haiti that's
amazing it it you know it improved lives
there in a very concrete way they got a
major federal grant to do it and for me
that's a great example of excellent
interfaith leadership because religious
communities and secular communities have
significant social capital volunteers
energy resources an interfaith leader
has the ability to mobilize that social
capital in ways that benefit a larger
community and so the interfaith leaders
that University of Illinois group were
able to go to the Muslim community the
Baha'i community the evangelical
community the Catholic community the
Jewish community secular humanist
community and bring them together for
this common project of packing meals for
Haiti and then they had this huge wall
where people could write their
inspiration to serve that was kind of
the interfaith dialogue part of the
project so there are biblical quotes on
that wall there are qur'anic verses
there are quotes from walt whitman from
secular humanism for me it's a great
example of an effective bridging of
social capital in ways that serve a
broader community and build interfaith
dialogue at the same time ok very good
let's move on to your book sacred ground
tell us a little bit about it and why
you feel it was important to write it
sure so in the summer of two thousand
ten America was caught in this huge
public discussion around the ground zero
mosque originally named Cordoba house
and the original vision of Cordoba house
was that it would be kind of a Muslim
YMCA an institution founded by a Muslim
community with with the resources of a
Muslim community but that was meant to
serve a broader public it was matt davis
swimming pool a culinary institute in
art gallery and it was meant to be based
in lower manhattan not far from where
imam feisal who was the founder of the
project had his head his mosque and
you'll remember that there was this huge
public discussion around this center and
it was it came to be called a terrorist
command center and Imam Feisal was
called a radical Imam and I remember
watching those news reports and reading
the papers and thinking that I'd entered
the twilight zone I mean I've known a
mom feisal for ten years I knew about
the plans for Cordoba house where they
were just being launched and and I
thought that this was actually a part of
of the Muslim process of of deeply
integrating in America in the sense that
our community was building an
institution whose primary purpose was
not to serve our own prayer needs but
was to serve a broader public's more
community or social needs
and so during that during that time I
started going back in American history
and looking at kind of the patterns of
religious prejudice and religious
pluralism in America and one of the
things that I discovered was that I
think across American history there's
been this dynamic of what i call the
forces of prejudice the forces that say
to some communities at different times
in history you don't belong right the
anti-catholic forces during earlier eras
the anti-semitic forces clearly the
racist forces in earlier areas of
American history saying you don't belong
and then the forces of pluralism the
force is saying actually the idea of
America is that we're a nation that
welcomes the contributions of all
communities and nurtures cooperation
between them those forces push back and
those forces have one era after era
after era and I kind of realized you
know we're in a new chapter of that
narrative of the the great narrative of
American pluralism versus American
prejudice and what this book is is it's
kind of a tracing of that of that story
across American history and in kind of
an explication of the chapter we're in
right now and it's a call to the forces
of pluralism of our era to stand up and
engage and defeat the forces of
prejudice whether it's anti Muslim
forces or anti-mormon forces or anti
atheist forces it is incumbent upon us
as Americans I think to recognize the
precious treasure of pluralism and our
nation's history but to know that that
it has to be protected and and and
that's what that's what sacred ground is
about don't you I think part of the
problem is the prejudice how do you get
beyond that how do you fix that so our
solution at interfaith youth core is to
is to first of all illuminate the story
of American pluralism I'll tell you one
one of my favorite parts of this when
George Washington first became president
he received a message from a Jewish
leader named Moses seshes effectively
asking whether his people Jews would be
safe in this new nation and Washington
wrote back a beautiful beautiful
document called the letter to the Hebrew
congregation of Newport Rhode Island
which said that America would give
bigotry no sanction and persecution no
assistance that's knowing the great
heritage of pluralism in America and I
think one of the one of the ways that
that the forces of pluralism in our era
gain strength is to know the heritage
and the legacy of pluralism in this
nation and they have a sense that we're
writing the next chapter in a glorious
story the skills of interfaith
leadership are really important as well
and I talked about this a bit in the
coca-cola lecture I gave yesterday
having an appreciative knowledge of
other religious traditions knowing about
the social gospel and Christianity
knowing about the role of mercy and
Islam we live in the most religiously
diverse nation in human history we ought
to know something appreciative about the
various religious communities of our
nation how they've contributed to to the
growth and success of America how their
values from Jainism or Buddhism are
similar to values and Catholicism or
Judaism it's it's it's something we at
interfaith youth core call interfaith
literacy and I think it's a key part of
being an effective interfaith leader
okay I think it's probably you know
there are some religions and some people
who you know believers who naturally
will work together but how do you handle
people who who are religious but are
just so filled with hate for another
form of religion how do you break that
down and deal with that yeah I think
that's a great question so in 15 years
of doing this work and and being in all
sorts of communities I've come to
believe that that the percentage of
people who hate somebody from another
religion is pretty small especially in
America right my sense is if you want to
think of this as a continuum there is a
there's there's a huge chunk of the
continuum that inclines in a really
proactive way towards being interfaith
leaders and then there's probably the
largest part of the continuum that's
relatively neutral or doesn't think
about this very often but certainly
opposed to it and then and then the the
part of the continuum that is opposed to
it is relatively small so the way we
work at interfaith youth core is to is
to look at the folks who are inclining
towards this and say you need to be
leaders who can go back to your
communities Geographic religious ethnic
racial etc and and convince them that
religious pluralism is something that
they have a stake in right so in a sense
what we do is inspire train and mobilize
young people on the on the end of the
continuum that is already inclining
towards this and it's a leadership
strategy right and there's plenty of
other strategies out there the one that
we're choosing the one that we're
betting on so to speak is is if we can
empower a critical mass of interfaith
leaders that will be the best way to
convince a critical mass of the nation
that protecting the precious treasure of
religious pluralism is something we
ought to be doing right and especially I
think it's important to their starting
as the their young people and as they
grow I think it will only help the
future of the country that's right you
know so so they'll have you know
god-willing 50 60 70 80 years to to be
advocates and leaders in protecting
pluralism right so if there is one thing
that you would like to leave us with
today what would it be what's the most
important thing you think we should take
away from our talk today I think it said
all of us need to be interfaith leaders
all of us need to recognize just how
important America's legacy of pluralism
is it is a remarkable thing that we live
in a nation whose very idea is to
welcome the contributions of various
communities and nurture cooperation
between them but that idea didn't fall
from the sky in the past and it it's not
inevitable that it remains the beating
heart of America we need a set of people
with the inspiration the knowledge base
and the skill set to protect that idea
and what that means is that we are able
to build bridges between individuals and
communities who orient around religion
differently and there's no more more
important time than
now America being the most religiously
diverse nation in human history the most
religiously devout nation in the West at
this time of global religious conflict
and I think about the the line from the
Parliament of the world's religions and
1893 in Chicago and I think this is a
kind of the mission statement of this
movement is is from now on the great
religions of the world make war no
longer on each other and instead on the
giant ills that afflict humankind sounds
wonderful thank you very much for being
here with us today i'm sharing some of
your work Thank You Marilyn for more
information about mr. Patel please visit
our website at yale edu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you
you